مجرد قفزة قفزة والقفز بعيدًا عن
برلين تكمن عجائب في رؤية spreewald
Germany spreewald تتكون من
ممرات مائية شاسعة غابات محمية من قبل اليونسكو ،
وأخيرًا وربما الأهم من ذلك ،
تشتهر spreewald بوجبة خفيفة مالحة
التي اشتهرت عالميًا spreewald gherkin كانت هذه
القصة الكبيرة العظيمة  أصبح ممكنًا من قبل المجلس
الوطني الألماني للسياحة
وتأمين السفر Hans Zimmer Corps ، فليس
سراً أن الجيركينز جزء من
الثقافة هنا وأن الجميع يريد التحدث
عنها يوصون ويقدمون
المشترك هنا في وقت لاحق لأن الروح لن
تختبر الديبولوس الآخرين في  اسمي
Colin stoic wait ، هل قلت للتو
متحف غيركينز أخبرني أكثر
من الواضح بما فيه الكفاية ، أليس
متحف الحبار هذا موقع منجم
في العالم ، لذلك حتى في الساعة 50 هذا
المساء قبطان الطعام الدكتور.  لقد تم
الحفاظ على ثني الناس في أليس لن نعم أنا
الدفاع سهل كما هو الحال في ذلك ، ثم أمسك خيارك
كارل ، لقد حان الوقت في الواقع
للذهاب واستكشاف المزيد من spreewald
بالقارب ، أعني punt استكشاف morph spreewald
بواسطة punt اسمي هو بدلة الطين يمكن أن
يتبع الديكي السرطان  رقصة المال kizomba
casteless plaza visage plaza اللانهائي الذي تسبب في المجاعة
قائلاً فقط الخوف لا
يرضي Amida
ولكن دعمه لأي لفتة مليون إلى حديقة الحيوان والنقش
في Yara كثيرًا بالهدية التي تظهر
تحت شفتهم يمكن أن يتظاهروا بهدوء
ولكن ماذا عن الجيركين  هل يمكنك
أن تأخذنا إلى
الجركين ، نعم غانا ، الجويد ليس
وعناصر مثل الطعام إلى منجم يقفز
skorca لا يوجه مرة أخرى ،
يا إلهي ، لقد نسيت أن أذكر أن
هناك ملكة غيركين شكرًا على
التذكير  مانفريد يجب أن نذهب لمقابلتها ،
نعم ، مرحبًا بيرة إسبينوزا ، لقد كان
أطفالًا صغارًا في كوبنهاغن ،
وماذا يعني ذلك بالضبط عندما
نأكل في الوقت الحاضر مفضلًا فقط من
الضرائب  intestinal 30 فوضويًا
تريد أكثر هدوءًا ماليًا ، تعال
إلى التواصل مع مفضلتك ، لذا
لدي سؤال
ما هو نوع gherkin المفضل لدي ،
كل شيء يفسد طلاب المدارس guca
فجأة أنا غابة تحليلية
[موسيقى]